i adriano ser conversa ea escrever só
você crianças e com quem aqui nunca para
que elas não totalmente que assim acusa
cinco minutos e vem falar física mas
talvez não da física
vocês teriam anda pensado não é porque
tem condições comentou que físicas
talvez a primeira coisa que nos vem à
cabeça seja por exemplo um dos grandes
físicos todos os tempos ou talvez um dos
maiores do século 20
o autor da história ou talvez nos vai na
cabeça
isaac newton é que o pai da física no
físico né
talvez nos vem à cabeça o cérebro
todas essas grandes equipamentos com
certeza vai aparecer nas notícias
faltou mesmo foi na cabeça o exame
difícil física fazendo há uns meses
atrás
a intenção não é que eu me aceito como
os programa provisão é só um cuba tem um
físico
tudo isso pode ser física mas também a
física é tudo isso e muito mais é isso
aqui é só produz tentar encontrar aquilo
que eu vou falar ok então o que é que é
física exatamente a ensinar isso aqui a
não fui eu que vi só que fez aqui tá
isso o seguinte se eu consigo ver para
lá e daquilo que eu vá diga só têm o que
significa que significa que a física a
física vai ser construída undertaker
gigantes vão convencer muitos gigantes
vão convencer muitos gigantes maneira
conseguirem ver cada vez mais velhas
certo então hoje em dia
conseguimos fato a versão é muito lança
programa estamos ao longo dos ciganos
como zagueiro ou albert einstein e e
acho que isso é importante dizer que no
fundo estamos numa situação de grande
conflito terminar porque realmente já
muita coisa foi descoberta sabemos muita
coisa
conseguimos ir muito grande na contava
ela falou com ele sobre isso nós
conseguimos ver desde muito grande das
galáxias até o infinitamente pequeno até
o tamanho mateus núcleos
- ainda agora isso também nos núcleos
conseguimos compreender o que acontece
em dias finalmente roubadas
conseguimos acompanhar existentes e
conseguimos a ter um deus para explicar
sobre esta talvez do mundo como um
player é porque no fundo isso que faz um
físico é um físico que faz 11 dizer é
colocar sal amo todos esses gigantes
olhar e simplesmente escrever aquilo que
está a ver para que outra pessoa possa
colocar os seus jogos e conseguir ver
ainda mais nós até então temos esses
cortes grandes modelos até temos por
exemplo o k4 é que ela não queria que
nós precisamos construir ali um ano
depois como possamos avançar para
denunciar os crimes mais altos ou três
dias pelo menos mais altas entrando na
área pra nós noite viram cair depois se
quisermos pensar que estamos a estudar o
infinitamente porque para isso
precisamos utilizar no cargo enquanto
estiver a pensar que são de outro a
estudar o enfrentamento que e ainda que
tem muita energia
vamos entrar no ramo da teoria quanto é
canto só que podemos também pensar em
dividir a física nessas áreas aqui eu
tenho a lista que são os modelos que
existem depois dessas áreas aqui vão
buscar um caminho cada um daqueles com
deus para poderem pra para poder ainda
realizará que quer analisar então vamos
falar da física nuclear e práticos
estrear alguns nunca inferior direito
daqui o corão em cima ok vamos falar da
física atômica em um ano qualquer
estamos a diminuir cada vez mais em
termos de energia e aumentar cada vez
mais a gente também
depois fazemos parte física da matéria
condensada até estamos também a aumentar
mesmo
o tamanho e diminui cada vez mais um dia
vamos continuando até chegamos a sua
filha de quem estamos a falar em tamanho
e influência muito grande mas também
podemos também para falar em duas vias
contempladas o deputado tem aqui então
já temos todas estas áreas e já estamos
todos assim dessa maneira nós vamos nos
gigantes
estamos confortáveis se calhar também
podemos pensar em utilizar tudo aquilo
que nós já conseguimos ver para
aplicações mais direta das práticas que
possam ser feitas no dia a dia para de
certa maneira conseguir melhorar e
ajudar a comunidade até então podemos
falar banking seria física se de
biofísica seu físico o elenco não física
física médica
as respostas a essas áreas que são no
fundo áreas em que as pessoas vão ganhar
em tudo aquilo que foi feito nas outras
áreas e tentar aplicá las no dia a dia e
eu venho falar essencialmente na área
das físicas boas condições o que é
importante é o que acontece quando nós
falamos em física e do exterior só esse
canalha que vai também é você começa a
mostrar alguma coisa o primeiro positivo
nessa se concentrar nas bombas nucleares
esperamos colaborar com o acidente de
fukushima após lembrar se das muitas
coisas que que sustentam em que nos
fazem pensar que o aumento não será
assim tão boa idéia dizendo compreender
esta coisa das condições né
mas falar é que a capacidade desta
tecnologia para a instituição e para
fazer o mal não são suas únicas
aplicações não é então aí é que eu gosto
eu gosto de fazer essa comparação não
falei com quando não ser mais conseguiu
dominar o fogo na época como quando você
não vai conseguir virar fosse pelas
primeiras aplicações também não foram
muito gentis
uma taquara também foram livro
comportamento estranho mas é um dinheiro
que a humanidade foi conseguindo
compreender e controlar essa tecnologia
am
podemos tentar utilizar essa tecnologia
para fazer o bairro para tentar melhorar
a coisa cuidado retirando as pessoas
apresentaram ligado à comunidade
podemos até pensar em transações
curiosas no princípio temos que imaginar
que a tecnologia o conhecimento da
radioatividade surgiu apenas no fim do
século 19 com os irmãos corrigir tudo
isso aconteceu há menos 150 anos e ainda
que essas coisas iam ficando então as
notícias a a a população em geral é
substancial se iam surgindo daí nossa
única vez investir cada vez mais
talvez agora nós olhando pra trás das
câmeras mas completamente ano fora
daquilo que seria do próprio grão e um
caso de câncer têm utilizado acabou de
virar para para ver o eficiente até hoje
isso parece uma coisa completamente fora
do normal não é utilizar a atividade por
atuar 1 da intenção ou para usar a
criatividade pra aquecer os pés ou
utilizar a rádio de virar para ver água
porque hopper água radioativa está este
um problema é que não consegui encontrar
procurava cadeia de valor e
eventualmente pudesse melhorar a saúde
das pessoas isso foram pessoas que as
pessoas que você nem parece um carro
localizada em braçadas faziam e no fundo
só estavam simplesmente experimentavam
tentar encontrar aplicação excluir essa
tecnologia na intenção é estabilizar
essa tecnologia e fato anos sabe
sistematizar sistematizar essas
essa situação e foram surgindo agências
e organizações nacionais precisamente
para tentar sinalizar a tecnologia na
avaliação de representantes da agência
nacional de energia atômica foi criado
em 1957 num musical da segunda guerra
mundial não é em como vocês sabem foram
usadas bombas atômicas no japão e na
china nakazaki e no fundo agências é
precisamente fazer assim ok
na verdade a tecnologia nuclear tem isto
ao texto alto poder destrutivo mas
também pode ser utilizada para a
produção a ciência também pode usar para
a prática pode ser utilizada para
respirar
então nós vamos criar a organização o
crescimento para que consigamos criar as
condições para que os países consigam
desenvolver ou criar conhecimento que
vai nesse sentido e para intervir também
certa forma unitária das bombas não era
como hoje nós só temos que estar sempre
certo como pintar assim como os países
para incluir no orçamento sejam
desenvolvidos extinto
tem uns dias para uso ilimitado surgiu
também o a atenção internacional para
obter sob o mote que serve também para
tentar perceber o que acontece com as
águias am e como é que nós podemos
proteger as pessoas daquela maneira
podemos utilizá ló sem que seja
prejudicial para nós mesmos
hoje em dia e acho que também não
fazendo nossa cabeça é utilizado em
todas estas áreas da ambição é utilizada
não só na indústria no caso da indústria
alimentar por exemplo serve para an
matar diz por exemplo não quiser querem
instrumentalizar uma fase devendo assim
podem podem utilizar a atenção para
fazer podem pensar que se calhar não foi
nenhum lance de destaque é toda a quadra
está não é nossa dentro das propriedades
tanto eu que me como um nutritivo dos
alimentos não só um não com essa cabeça
nessa integração mortos visto também é
utilizado na construção também é
utilizado para fazer tanto no caso do
esquema de sempre utilizar para mover a
necessidade do sol quando constrói
estradas por exemplo também fazia isso
curiosamente ao contrário do que muita
gente possa pensar também utilizado no
ambiente ok por exemplo com o torcedor é
possível estudar por exemplo o
crescimento das plantas da flora é
possível fazer a monitorização nos dias
07 e portanto também podem utilizar a
atenção nesse sentido e quarta também
tem a aplicação do decreto a gente né
inicia e tem a atenção também do
no entanto a sua música tem que pode ser
usada tanto ouvir nosso como na
áustralia ok etapa passamos aqui as
aplicações na medicina não foi um quem
possa pensar que esta área da física não
dá prêmios nobel é lotar mas temos aqui
um caso não treinou foi tranquilo
raúl disse que eu ia forma em 1978 pelas
correta ou pelos alunos fizeram uma
tomografia assistida por computador mais
que o que acontece é uma pretensão
portuguesa
nesses casos a versão x para produzir
imagens extremamente precisas do
interior do corpo humano não é tão
precisas am como nunca foram antes
impossíveis de serem realizadas e isso é
um grande avanço da ciência e prometeu
que mesmo assim não também um avanço na
capacidade de diagnóstico e prevenção de
doenças usando essa tecnologia ao mesmo
tempo que só ter com certeza você
dizendo vida foi também desenvolvido a
tecnologia dos radiofármacos são fazer
uma descrição marcados com 1 com a romã
contra dois acadêmicos também são os
detalhes das pessoas e também espero
também fazer imagens do interior do
corpo humano extremamente precisas e
podem inclusivamente ser combinados
junto com os outros equipamentos desse
tipo para fazer
para fazer fiscalizações muito finas ou
do corpo humano e é isso mas quem é fã
no caso do diagnóstico meus passaram por
causa do canto e eu estava a mostrar
esta esta imagem que mostra uma senhora
d'agonia que o desapontamento campo ea
mesma linha entre o tanque quando
combinamos isto podemos fazer tratamento
por exemplo aqui nesse caso estamos
falando também de um kangoo no no
cérebro e podemos ver que conseguimos já
com as tecnologias atuais utilizando
esses equipamentos forneceram uma grande
dose de atenção no tecido tumoral
enquanto esse ponto 1 817 só quem faz
isto está uma grande fila enorme até
conseguir ter sido coisa que não só a
nível da ambição com o tamanho da
produção de imagem conversaram no
entanto chegamos ao ponto em que já
conseguimos fazer coisas disse serra
no fundo isto é a senhora tem a vencer a
batalha contra a américa
conseguimos ver se está a tentar
aumentar a mortalidade do cancro está a
diminuir isso também vem como forma de
nós conseguimos temos essas tecnologias
para procurar um campo utilizado na
cabeça
e é isso eu acho que para por aqui tanto
que eu queria dizer é que no fundo nós
não somos nós somos cartões sombrios do
gigante
estamos a tentar fazer alguma coisa no
dia a dia para contribuir para essa
pequena coisa
vamos todos ao mesmo tempo fazer
conseguimos avançar e conseguir fazer
com que as coisas né